[Applause]
we are here with chloe grace moretz who
is starring in tom and jerry
uh the new film which we're all so
excited about as parents who get to
watch something
new with our kids but that harkens back
to not only the cartoons that we all
grew up with
but
i watched tom and jerry
every day with my kids
why did you want to do this
this is so exciting thank you for this
gift chloe honestly it makes me so happy
to to to hear you say exactly that you
know i grew up with tom and jerry from
the time i was a little little girl my
mom grew up with it from the time she
was a little girl my brothers and i and
so i really think it's one of those you
know uh
cartoons that's really been
generationally in in our lives for so
long and i really jumped at the
opportunity to not only bring this piece
back into the modern day but also be
able to do this live action you know
plus animation kind of world similar to
roger rabbit which i grew up with as
well and introduce it to you know young
kids that that you know have never seen
tom and jerry in at all you know what i
mean so it's a really fun um i think
multi-generational uh project bring on
the chases it's like it's funny yeah
yeah no that's exactly it bring on the
antics
bring on the the slapstick comedy and we
filmed this back in 2019 which is you
know pre uh the the pandemic so i think
now more than ever this is really the
perfect movie to be coming out so we can
all just sit together and check out for
a little while and smile and laugh and
not think about our day to day i just
love this world and i do think that
people need more entertainment in their
homes that they can enjoy on their own
or with their kids or that their kids
could enjoy
we need that because we're all stuck at
home together
yeah
okay chloe i know this is going to sound
like a weird segue but is it true did
you set up megan traynor with her
husband i just saw that
yeah
yeah
daryl uh daryl sabara was one of my
closest friends when we were i was like
15 years old we did a stephen soderbergh
play together um
called the library and uh years later i
met megan and uh we totally hit it off
as friends and she was like i'm looking
for a good guy and i was like well my
very very very close friend is you know
one of the nicest guys i've ever met i
think you guys would totally hit it off
they headed off they fell in madly in
love and now they have a baby which is
crazy it's like a true a true match made
in heaven that is so cool do you know
how many girls out there are so happy
because like wouldn't so many people
love to have their friend have their
back and be like let's try this what
matchmaking is such a wonderful thing
it's so wonderful sometimes it totally
blows up in your face i've done it a few
times where like they've not hit it off
and i'm like i'm so sorry but with this
one it really was one of those just like
perfect you know uh serendipitous things
and and it's been so wonderful to see
their relationship bloom and blossom and
now with a new life it's just i mean and
his birthday he's four days after mine
so it was crazy he was born four days
after me and i was like what is going on
here it's all sounds so serendipitous
and besher and perfect are you gonna
match make again now that you're like
amazing at it and who cares some don't
work out that's life you know but are
you gonna try it again
i mean let's see let's see if i can uh
if i could if i can keep my batting
average high you know what i mean i'm
trying
trying to keep it there chloe i think
everything you touch turns to gold so
whether it's a film or just getting to
work with you and know you and be your
friend or it's setting up couples that's
going to change their life i think you
can do it all of course
thank you thank you thank you i'm going
to try i'm going to try
oh baby flea flee
because that's that's that's what we we
were mama flea and baby flea making a
beautiful short film that
um some of the best directors i've ever
known steven spielberg and martin
scorsese have been like we love this i'm
like chloe you and i made something that
impressed the two greatest filmmakers
ever to live on planet earth
i know i know which is which is wild i
definitely think we should try and do it
again um and this time maybe a
full-length as like as soon as possible
chloe grace in fact we're gonna put the
short film and its full length up on the
drewberrymore show.com so if you want to
look at
something that i was lucky enough to
make with chloe we'd love to share it
with you chloe grace moretz tom and
jerry premieres today thank you it
couldn't come soon enough in select
theaters and hbo max where it's all
happening baby flea i love you i'm so
happy to see you thank you for coming on
the show
[Music]